the biggest names in the NBA are coming
after world champion American Sprinter
Noah Lyles after he made a pretty
outrageous statement about the league
the 2023 Sprint Champion was asked about
the state of sports champions and he
said what hurts him the most is when he
has to watch the NBA Finals Champions
where world champions on their heads he
then said world champion of what the
United States qkd Booker Dame bam and a
ton of other NBA stars who also flooded
the comments book dropped this Emoji
Katie said someone has to help Lyles
Aaron Gordon said whatever I'm smoking
buddy in the 200 meter Dame was confused
bam needed someone to let Lyles know PJ
Tucker couldn't believe it I mean the
list goes on and on there were even some
NFL players in the mix Le'Veon Bell
backed the NBA players up by pointing
out how the best players in the world go
to the NBA that is the reality the NBA
has long been considered the best league
in the world and mostly all the best
international players come to the US to
play USA Basketball also has an
outstanding record at the Olympics and
other International competitions